[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
GARY GENSLER: Welcome
back to fintech.
We're getting together
for our fourth class,
and we're going
to get going now.
Thank you for tying in online
via this modern technology.
Today we're going to move to
important customer interfaces--
user interfaces and
user experiences that
have been greatly enhanced
by open application program
interfaces.
Now, application
program interfaces
is not new to finance, and it
didn't start in M&A finance.
It's a basic concept
of how one computer is
talking to another computer.
And again, this is not a
computer science class,
but we're going to spend
a little bit of time
on what application
program interfaces are
and what this
concept of open API
is and some of the
companies around it
and how companies have
organized themselves,
both in terms of finance,
and a little bit even
outside of finance and some
of the challenges with regard
to that.
What API has also led
to is a movement of
and a greater concentration
around companies
called data aggregators.
And we'll get into that as well.
As I've sort of worked through
with the class already,
it's my thought that
certain technologies
have been moving into the
finance technology stack,
and are really part and parcel
to what finance is in 2020.
And I think open API, with its
movement around the globe--
and some countries have
moved further in it,
some countries have moved
less, some companies have moved
further, some companies
have moved less--
that this is a
trend that will be
fully incorporated into the
technology stack of finance
country by country, if it
hasn't already been so.
But it's been a major disruptor
in the last five, seven years.
And it will continue to
be a bit of a disruptor
for the next handful of years.
By the end of this
decade, we'll look back,
we'll say that that's
probably already happened,
and there'll be
enhancements around it.
But we'll be fully inside of it.
Maybe not as dramatic as
artificial intelligence
and machine learning
to our minds--
thinking of machines
extracting correlations
better than we can.
But I think it's
fairly dramatic,
in terms of the
advancement of finance
and all that we
have in front of us.
So that's why I decided to
take one class and one lecture
on it.
I also want to thank everybody.
Romain put out a survey.
About a third of you took it.
It was a voluntary survey.
And it's helpful.
And what I took back from
the desires of students were
could I do a little bit more
talking about the companies
in the fintech space?
And maybe add, if I might say,
a little less, whether it's
on the broader technology
or broader policy side.
I'll do my best.
But I also want
to share with you
why I think there's
a reason to have
some foundation-- some
foundation of what
the technologies are,
or even some foundation
on the public policy
side, as we move
into the latter
part of this class.
The latter part of this class is
really to talk sector by sector
what the competitive landscape
is, which companies are up,
which companies are
down, and so forth.
But as we've already
talked about a bit today,
the companies really matter.
And I'll sort of interject
that more as we go forward
during this semester.
One other question is whether we
could have some guest speakers.
I'm kind of going to have
to apologize in advance.
This is kind of what you get.
But over the next
handful of sessions,
if I come up with somebody
to bring in-- it's
a little hard at this juncture
to bring in guest speakers.
But I certainly
appreciate the request.
And with four weeks
to go, you never know.
But with that, I'm going to
start to share some slides.
I don't know, Romain
if you have anything
you took from the feedback,
which was very helpful.
PROFESSOR 2: Thank you.
Thank you very much for
filling out the survey.
That was great.
Just two small
announcements from my side.
One, a reminder for
your team formation.
Friday is the deadline.
Please register your teams
in Canvas in the People's tab
using the Groups function.
If you don't know
how to do that,
I'll be happy to show you.
So please register your teams
of three to four students
for the group assignments.
And then second reminder,
as per the syllabus,
have one of your team
members just send me
an email saying what is the
topic that you wish to study
for your group assignments.
Please don't forget to do that.
The deadline is also
Friday, April the 10th.
Thank you.
GARY GENSLER: Thank you.
And part of that is
just to really help
you engage in this subject.
To Romain and myself, it doesn't
matter which sector you pick
or whether you choose
to sort of write
your paper from the perspective
of incumbents, to big tech,
or to a venture capitalist.
But it's really to
help you sort of engage
in the world of fintech,
that which we're studying,
and to pick one sector.
And are you taking it from
the entrepreneurial strategy
of the disruptor,
or are you taking it
from a big firm, either
incumbent or a tech firm's
perspective in this regard?
So as I said, we're going
to talk a little bit
about application
program interface, how
this fits into the
history of finance,
deeper dive in open
API and open banking.
You were all asked
to prepare and sort
of look at the Bank of
International Settlements
report.
So I'm not going to dive in.
I'm going to hopefully
assume that you've had
a chance to engage with that.
And then talk a little bit
also about data aggregators
and a movement amongst many
in large financial firms
to have a standard
setting group--
a financial data
exchange on open APIs.
And then try to close out a
little bit on robotic process
automation.
So a lot to cover.
But I think we'll keep it going.
And I ask again,
use the Participate
button to raise the blue hands.
Use the chat function.
Romain's going to
keep interrupting me.
And we'll have hopefully
a good session together.
So the readings, again, Bank
of International Settlements,
this consortium of 60 or so
central banks around the globe,
stands up reports
and studies from time
to time on new challenges
they're seeing.
So just that they pick this
topic to write a report that
came out this past
November of 2019
is indicative right
there in and of itself
that it's a movement
around the globe that they
thought they needed to study,
and an important aspect.
I picked one article
out of the many articles
that you can grab off the
internet about fintech
for the next decade.
And this was one article
that I thought was relevant,
because it really
did also include
this concept of the interface--
the customer user interface
and what was going on
with regard to APIs.
And then one
article, again, just
to give you sort of a primer
on robotic process automation
that I think is
relevant as well.
So again, just if anybody wants
to give a little short brief as
to what are the major
trends on the marketing side
that's affecting financial
services right now.
And we can go broader
than API, of course.
But Romain anybody want
to sort of contribute now?
PROFESSOR 2: Let's
see, who will be
our first volunteer of the day?
Michael.
AUDIENCE: Not sure if this
is exactly marketing side,
but I think customer
trust is maybe more--
must have trust in
connecting your personal data
to a third party.
I'm thinking something
like mint.com,
where I add my bank account.
I can connect it
and feel comfortable
giving that information to a
site that's not necessarily
my bank or my credit card.
GARY GENSLER: Absolutely.
Absolutely.
So one of the major changes--
and this has been
a number of years,
as companies like
Mint and others,
where you'll give
your data to a company
that you've personally
never met a human being.
You've downloaded an app
and you're giving your data
to that company,
to give you advice
or to give you a better rate.
Have you used Mint, by the way?
And do you mind just saying what
product were you shopping for,
or what service were
you looking for?
AUDIENCE: I was just trying
to track my spending because I
was spending way too much.
GARY GENSLER: All
right, so there are also
sites where it can help you
keep your personal budget,
if you wish--
like personal
accounting and so forth.
And you give them permission
to look into your bank account.
But this trend of using--
and there many
competitors of Mint
that we'll dive into in
the next couple weeks.
But there are many competitors.
It's basically
saying, all right,
I am going to
permission a website--
a data service provider,
fintech company--
I'm going to permission them
to look inside my bank account.
I have to give them my password
and my username in some way
and have them linked in.
Big change.
It takes away a little of the
comparative advantage possibly
of the big incumbents, because
you and I can give somebody
else permission to go in
and look at that data.
PROFESSOR 2: [? Iqbal? ?]
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Morning, professor.
I just want to
highlight that there's
an avenue to market or to
showcase financial services.
It's starting to be on
a lifestyle platform.
So if you look at, for example,
Alipay, it's all about access
to [INAUDIBLE] online shopping.
And WeChat's about
access to its gaming.
But there's a lot of these
conflicting financial services
and key services
that people want.
So it's nothing new.
In fact, Walmart and even
now [? Star Market ?]
has banks opened up
within its grocery stores.
So I think there'll
be a trend that
will be for the [INAUDIBLE].
GARY GENSLER: And so what
[? Iqbal ?] has raised is not
new-- decades old--
that even big retailers,
bricks and mortar retailers,
thought, well, should we
have a counter for you
to do some finance?
Should we embed finance
into the retailing business
with the trends with
in-store and branded credit
cards for decades?
But now online
embedded finance inside
of Alipay, which was mentioned
just then, and other companies,
to embed the financial
aspects right in their product
offerings.
And some of that
embedded finance
is an Amazon credit card or
an Alipay payment mechanism.
Some of the embedded
finance can even
be that if you're buying
a mattress from Casper--
I think I may have
referenced this already--
but if you're buying a
mattress from cash online,
that they might offer what's
called point-of-sale financing.
Now, you and I don't
think of it that way.
They just say, you can pay
over four installments.
But in fact, they're lending
you money for those four
installments, and it's
embedded right in the product.
And Uber and Lyft actually
embed some finance right
in their app.
Now, they've built it on top
of credit card companies.
But they could
choose to build it
on top of their own sort
of financing mechanism
with their drivers and the like.
So big change, embedded finance.
Multi decades in
coming, but now it's
embedded finance in
a technological way
that it looks
seamless to the user--
or can look seamless.
PROFESSOR 2: Nikhil.
AUDIENCE: The other
piece that I thought
was interesting was the article
talk about first the uncoupling
of financial services.
So a lot of fintech incumbents
decouple the product offerings.
But then there's a resurgence
of bundling products again.
So when you look at
Wealthfront, they
started with just
asset management.
But now they're offering
cash management.
Robinhood's the same way.
It came out trading,
but again, they're
trying to pivot to
cash management.
So they focus on very niche
products to begin with,
but there seems to be
bundling happening again.
GARY GENSLER: Right.
And I think this is
unbundling and rebundling
happens in many industries.
Some of the proponents in
the most optimistic side
of financial
technology say, we can
have a flattening of finance.
We can have a full
unbundling, where
you can get each of your
products separately.
And while the
technology can and does
facilitate that, I
think our tendencies
in markets and as humans,
and our behavioral science
tells us that bundling happens.
So even if this transitional
period of time--
even if this late 20-teens
and early 2020's allows
for a lot of unbundling, I
believe that a lot of this
will stay bundled and rebundled
within particular websites,
particular product offerings.
I don't know of Leonora
is trying to speak,
because your name's popping
up here on the screen.
But if not-- how would
open API initiatives
influence all of this?
I've sort of said it
a little bit myself,
but anybody want to chime in?
PROFESSOR 2: Geetha?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I think I
speak from the incumbent side.
I think open APIs have made
it so easy from a banking
perspective, in terms of ability
to track what is being accessed
of customer data.
Because before APIs
and before some
of the standouts
like OAuth and OIDC,
they were pretty much
dependent on screen scraping.
And it was very difficult
for us to track.
And the customers pretty much
gave their user ID and password
to these vendors.
And they could pretty much log
in and screen scrape anything,
and we won't even know.
GARY GENSLER: So you're saying
Gita, from the incumbent side--
from the big financial firm
side, these new startups--
the Mints of the
world, so to speak--
were able to get folks'
usernames and passwords,
and come into the
incumbent systems,
and grab the data
through a method
called screen scraping, or
even through a robotic process
automation, which we're
going to chat about.
And you're saying you feel from
an incumbent side it's better
to manage all of that--
those interfaces, which
could be disruptive.
You'd have more awareness
and more security
around that interface.
AUDIENCE: Correct.
GARY GENSLER: And then
how does it influence it
from the consumer side?
Anybody want to throw an
idea from the customer side?
I agree with what Gita's saying.
PROFESSOR 2: So I'm not
sure it will be related,
but Yi had his hand up.
GARY GENSLER: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
think the benefits
is more for the fintech company
rather than the incumbent.
Because it basically
lowered the entry barriers.
So I guess from the
consumer perspective,
now you have many more options.
Previously, you can only work
with those like large banks.
But now you can work with many
more companies that are there.
So the market is more
competitive, basically.
GARY GENSLER: So if I
permission a company like Mint,
Mint can give me advice around
my cash flow management.
If I have permission
a company like so
SoFi, which is, frankly,
competing with the banks--
competing with lending products.
But if my SoFi to
see my accounts,
then I get more
options as a consumer.
SoFi might compete
with the banks,
but also give me a better user
interface-- user experience
as well.
So it's far broadened out
the world for the consumers.
And then I put a
couple of readings
in about robotic process
automation and screen scraping.
Gita's already
raised this a bit.
And it's being used.
It's also being used by
the financial sector.
So anybody want to add how you
think about robotic process
automation in a positive way?
In a way from the incumbents
and the financial firms,
how they're using it.
It's certainly also being
used by the disruptors trying
to get information
out of the incumbents.
They're using it as sort of
an automated screen scraping
to grab information
from the incumbents.
But does anybody
want to sort of say
how maybe the
incumbents are using it
in their business models?
PROFESSOR 2: Hassan.
AUDIENCE: Hi, professor.
Yeah, I just have a
question about the APIs.
I don't actually totally
understand what are these.
I mean, is it like
an operating system?
I mean, what's an API exactly?
I've tried to google it, but
I've not quite understood.
GARY GENSLER: So I'm
going to dive into it.
Can I hold that, Hassan,
just for a minute?
Because I'm going to dive into
it in the next six minutes.
But fundamentally, an
application program interface
is a method that two
computers can speak to.
And the traditional
way, and the old way,
it was just how one system
can go in and get information,
get objects out of
the other system.
And then we'll do a
little cursory dive
into what it looks like today.
Because it's moved a lot
from that traditional method.
On a web-based API system, you
can actually sort of almost--
it feels like on your computer,
on your laptop, so to speak,
that you're actually operating
that system at a distance.
So you sort of think of it like
it's not only just grabbing
some data or objects or
records, but it's actually
sort of grabbing
some application,
as if it feels
like you're really
operating it on your system.
Open API is this
conceptual framework
that it's a public
interface, rather than
a private interface.
And if you think that
you could literally
have just a restricted private
interface that you give one
other computer, whether
it's an affiliate of yours
or a customer of yours,
a contractual private
interface to do that which
they wish to do, or is it
a public interface, where
broadly it can be interfaced?
And so that's sort
of a thumbnail.
But let me sort of develop
that a little bit more
over the next half hour.
Does that help?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Thank you very much.
PROFESSOR 2: So to answer
your question, Gary,
we have Ivy and then Andrea.
GARY GENSLER: OK.
And then I'll move on.
Thanks, Ivy.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I just wanted
to answer the question.
Because I thought the
Medium article did
a good job of talking
about the different ways
that are banking use cases.
And I've actually
gone through a lot
in terms of just
on the banking side
like actually having to do
customer onboarding and KYC.
And like we actually have
what's called a KYC analyst.
So all this is actually
very, very manual typically.
And going through
compliance checks,
we'll be working on a deal,
and at the last minute,
you can't get compliance
checks through.
And it's usually a huge pain.
So I was excited to see
that they could potentially
change the system,
because it ends up
being a huge headache
for everyone.
I think my question, though, is
like, when I read about this,
obviously it seems like--
I'm sure the
technology is there.
But I think about just like
any bulge bracket banks--
their IT infrastructure
has been in place
for like 50-plus years.
And changing that
technology is like removing
one piece of a really
big complicated puzzle.
So I almost just question
how feasible that is.
Like the article does
a really good job
of laying out what we
can actually automate.
But I guess I am a
little bit skeptical as
to like when that
time will come.
GARY GENSLER: And Ivy,
may I ask which bank
or what country you were
working in that was doing this?
AUDIENCE: I worked at
Merrill and Barclays.
GARY GENSLER: So Merrill-Lynch
or Barclays, you're right,
they're incumbents.
And they can
automate many things.
The technology is in advance
of what they are actually
doing right now.
But robotic process automation
can provide both incumbents
and disruptors.
But the Merrills and
Barclays are already
using it to some
extent to automate
that which humans are doing.
Some of it, as we'll
dive into later on,
is about reading documents.
Just literally an object
reading a document.
You could say that one form
of robotic process automation
that we already have is when
we can deposit a check by using
our mobile phone.
Now, that also uses natural
language processing,
and it sort of reads that into
the computer, and so forth.
But you're absolutely right
that each in incumbent
is dedicated to ensuring that
if they're moving from a legacy
system to a new system, that
they do that in their own way,
so that it doesn't
break in the middle,
and that they actually
do save money.
And they have to schedule it.
And they might not get to
that project for 18 months
or even five or seven years.
And sometimes that's what
gives the fintech disruptor
the opportunity--
that the incumbent can
use a new technology.
In this case, RPA.
They can use that technology.
But they can't schedule it for
three years or even longer.
Or if they're
scheduling it, they
have to do it in a
very controlled way.
And the disruptor
then is coming along
and having an opportunity
in the meantime
to attack that business model.
So I thank you.
Romain are there others,
or should I move on?
PROFESSOR 2: We finally
had Andrea, who I believe
has experience on this topic.
So we could all benefit from it.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, but I wanted
to add a similar point that we
just discussed with Ivy.
So we can move on definitely.
But what I appreciate about
the RPA in the incumbents
is that it helps
them to increase
the efficiency in operations.
But at the same time, it also
brings in the standardization.
And people can focus--
or employees of the bank
can focus on more
value-adding services.
For example, the advisory
to the client when
it comes to more
difficult products,
such as mortgages
or consumer loans.
But at the same time,
as you mentioned,
the time and the resources
that you need, especially
in huge incumbents like
Merrill or Barclays,
it takes a lot of
time to get there.
GARY GENSLER: Right.
And so what's interesting about
each of these technologies--
and this is true if
we broaden it out--
open API, robotic
process automation,
they're both a tool
for the disruptors
to produce services
and new business models
to the consuming public,
And, they're also
tools to the
incumbents, depending
upon on how they can
invest in those tools, how
they can update their
business models, and the like.
And in particular in open
API, we'll see there's a real
challenge, that the
large incumbents--
the JPMorgan Chases and the
PNC Banks and so forth--
are sharing data now with
a lot of the disruptors.
They're providing greater
services to their ultimate end
users and customers.
But then also they're
concerned about,
are they giving up some of their
inherent competitive advantage
of controlling that data?
And so there's some
real trade offs,
particularly in
the open API world,
as to how banks look at this.
So I wanted to go back to the
question of like, what is API?
I just was able to find
a slide of TechTarget
that I thought was helpful,
just to think about this.
An API, just think
of two systems
that are linking together.
And sort of the original APIs
was just a local application
program interface that sort
of could connect two computers
together.
Web-based API, which went
further-- and web-based APIs
have been around for 30 years.
This is not a new technology.
But web-based are
designed really
to represent such that
they could be widely used.
HTML now and later
something called
REST API, which is more
recently, these are protocols.
These are protocols that
multiple parties on the web
can come into your
service in some way.
And then we talk
about public APIs,
which really sort of
broadens it out further.
And you could even
think of this as sort
of private registered APIs
to broadly publicly available
APIs.
And what many businesses
are trying to use--
and they manage it.
And it's a very active
part of strategy,
is to manage that interface
to allow the developer
community to interface
with your platform.
Facebook needs to do it.
Instagram needs to do it.
Any network-based or
platform-based service actually
wants to encourage developers
to build applications
on top of the platform.
So now you bring
this to finance.
Does JPMorgan Chase, does Bank
of America, does Barclays, does
Merrill want to do the same--
encourage development
of applications
on top of their platform?
Recognizing that they make
a lot on their platform--
their balance sheet, their
funding models, their data,
their analytics.
Do they want to encourage the
development of applications
on top?
And it's a little bit of a push
and pull, because they're also
encouraging development
of applications
that might compete
with them, but also
enhance what they're doing.
So I sort of found this
other spaghetti slide
that I thought was
really helpful.
Now, if you think
about thousands
of financial firms dealing
with thousands of public,
this spaghetti wire
gets even worse.
But application
program interface
is a classic problem of math.
It's that if you only have two
computers by two computers,
you might need four
lines of connections.
But all of a sudden
when you have thousands,
you could have this
spaghetti wire of interfaces.
So what's happened in the midst
of this in sector by sector
is that there have
been companies
that really have an API
management layer in between.
And in many sectors,
you've seen a consolidation
around either one standard
for APIs or companies
that are really service
providers in the middle.
And here are some
examples in non-finance.
And whether you know
underneath the hood
about Twilio or others--
Twilio probably has,
I'm told, something
close to an 80% market share
in voice and messaging.
That they're sort of that
layer in between the disruptors
and the service providers
and the classic companies,
providing a layer in the middle.
A layer in the middle.
Checkr does it on employment
checks when we want a check.
Each one of these companies
were startups over the last 20
years.
Salesforce is a
little bit earlier.
And they really took--
even if they didn't
know it at the time,
they took the concept of open
API and API and they built it.
And in fact, there's these
words they call API first--
that you can build
a strategy saying,
we're going to be the
best providing APIs.
Now, who's done this in finance?
Who's done this in finance?
One company that you might
think of as a payment service
provider, Stripe,
did it very well.
Stripe basically said, we
will be that API provider
in the payment space.
What company did it really well
most recently that we talked
about last class was Plaid.
And we're going to come
back into Plaid as well.
But Plaid did this very well.
Now, they didn't
start by saying,
we're going to be
only an API company.
But they did start with
being an API company.
It was two entrepreneurs,
in Plaid's case,
about six or seven
years ago that said,
there really isn't a good
API in the payment space.
Now, there was Stripe.
And I'm not sure about
their foundational stories,
why they didn't feel that the
Stripe APIs were good enough.
But they created an API.
And of course, Plaid just
recently sold for $5 billion
plus to Visa, or
announced the sale.
So we talked a little
bit about finance
and this history, the stack.
And I'm going back to the
customer interface stack.
We don't need to go back
to bricks and mortars
and electronic payments.
But again, sort of the
conceptual framework
of this class and
how I think about it,
the most recent things
added to the stack--
the internet, mobile phones,
contact cards, and the like--
those are all fully engaged and
part of the finance technology
stack.
And now we're adding
open API and chat
bots, which we talked
about last class,
and natural language
processing, robotic processing.
We're adding that to the
finance technology stack.
And that's sort of the
conceptual framework.
And I think those are where
the opportunities are.
In five or eight or
10 years from now,
it will be taken for granted.
Of course, there'll
be enhancements.
And every change,
there's an enhancement
that creates some
opportunities as well.
So what do we mean by open API?
To [? Iqbal's ?]
earlier question.
Open Application
Program Interface
provides developers
access to and an ability
to get permissioned
customer data.
That means you and I
give a password, you
and I give a username.
Open banking
initiatives-- open banking
is unique to the
financial world--
are initiatives usually
promoted by the official sector.
Usually promoted either
by the central banks
or by the banking
regulators, and sometimes
promoted by
competition authority,
to say you must
share certain data
or you must create some
standards for these open APIs.
And again, as I just
mentioned, open APIs
are in every field
of online services,
from voice to
employment to retailing.
But the competition authorities
and the central banks
around the globe
said, well, maybe we
should lean into this--
the official sector-- lean
in and promote competition
for this sharing of data.
And these initiatives,
which you've
got a chance to read about,
do have policy trade offs.
And why I focus on
these policy trade offs
is they're also
about competition.
Incumbents are not
going to really want
to embrace
competition like this.
Having said that,
many of the incumbents
recognize that it might
be that they're shifting
right now-- that their
business models are shifting,
and they have to think
like platform companies.
And to the extent that the
JPMorgans or the Barclays
think more like
platform companies,
they want to encourage
the developer community
to develop applications
on top of their platforms.
If they think it's simply
losing market share to the SoFis
and to the new
banks, then they're
going to be more
closed to open API.
If they think more like
platform companies,
they're going to
want to promote it.
But there are also trade offs.
There are also trade offs
that the big incumbents
would say about cybersecurity.
If we just let anybody
into our platform,
they can also bring down
that platform possibly.
And so these are real
public policy trade offs,
but they're also commercial
trade offs as well.
[Romain I don't know if
there was a question.
I see some activity in the chat.
PROFESSOR 2: We have a
question from Geetha.
GARY GENSLER: Please.
PROFESSOR 2: Gary, I've been
thinking a lot about incumbents
becoming platforms.
Other than an ability to allow
access to their customer data
to lenders, I'm
not able to think
of examples of what kind of
platforms incumbents can be.
Like, they are not a
specific payment company.
They're only servicing
their own customers.
So I wonder if you
have any examples.
GARY GENSLER: So I think
many of the major banks
are already platforms.
They don't necessarily think
of themselves this way,
but they are bringing together--
and this is true for centuries--
they are bringing together
borrowers and
lenders, or savers.
So they have a balance
sheet that brings together,
in some cases, millions of
savers and tens of thousands
or hundreds of
thousands of borrowers.
And they're bringing
that together.
And when you consider that sort
of the modern large financial
firm with $1 trillion or
$2 trillion balance sheet,
many of the largest [? were ?]
[? all-- ?] and so forth.
And so they're
bringing that together,
and they're managing risk.
And they're very good
at it, or some of them
are very good at
that risk management
of those millions of
depositors and tens
or hundreds of
thousands of borrowers.
That in itself is a platform.
That creates a data
advantage that they
have about risk management.
And it could be a real one.
And they can offer activities
and products on top of that.
The fintech startups
can be, in a sense,
a front end distribution
channel to bring more in.
Because a lot of
the fintech startups
don't have that same
balance sheet capability--
that same ability to in
essence earn a spread
between savers and borrowers.
Now, you might contend,
well no, they're
losing their
competitive advantage,
because those startups
sort of have that customer
interface, that direct--
one might consider it the
last mile with that customer.
But the technology companies
have taken another approach
in saying, we like developers
developing applications
on top of our platforms.
We think it brings
more activities.
We think it brings more
interface, more data.
And so they're sort of a
network that is bringing data
and activity on the platform.
But I agree with you.
It's a real strategic trade off.
It's a real strategic challenge.
And the incumbents are
still sorting it out.
PROFESSOR 2: Camilo?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, hi.
I just wanted to ask, in
one of the other lectures,
they tried to classify
the open banking between
[? prescriptive, ?]
to facilitate
market-driven, and in-process.
But there were many countries,
as for example Colombia, who
didn't have any classification.
What's the meaning of that?
It means that it's forbidden.
I mean, is it impossible
to scrape the data
from that from the bank?
GARY GENSLER: So
it's a good question.
The Bank of International
Settlements paper I think
is to which you refer.
And what they did was country
by country review where it is.
And in fact, that's
probably good
leading to the map that was
in that report that I'll show.
In many countries, the
central bank, bank regulators,
and competition authorities
have not said much.
I'm not close enough
to Colombia to know.
But in those countries, you
can still technologically
go in and scrape.
An alternative,
as I lay out here,
is actually scraping
from the screen.
And so I think actually
it's the next--
I grab this slide from the Bank
of International Settlements
reports.
And thank you, it's a
great setup, Camilo.
That Europe passed
something called
the Payments System Directive.
And it was actually
the second time
that the European parliament
came together and said,
we need to promote in
the payment space--
not necessarily in
the lending space,
but in the payment space--
that there's more
availability from merchants
and from fintech startups
to access your data and move
money.
That's Europe.
And as the Bank of
International Settlements says,
it's more prescriptive.
In the countries that are gray
on this map-- most of Africa,
many parts of the
Mideast, and so forth,
parts of Latin America--
the Bank of International
Settlements, I should say,
only covers about 60 countries.
So many of the
parts that are gray
are countries that Bank of
International Settlements
didn't survey.
But those countries
are probably,
like the US, technically
market-driven.
There is no federal
law in the US,
and there's no
banking rule, that
prescribes that you must
have open API in the US.
So I think that in Colombia
it might be a technically
market-driven, where
the startups are using
some form of screen scraping
and some form of robotic process
automation.
But what we found in the US
is companies like Stripe,
companies like Plaid,
others that I'm
going to list in a moment,
like Yodlee and others,
just built a business model
out of creating public APIs.
And the incumbents
possibly in Colombia
are dealing with the same.
I don't know.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Well, I don't know.
In Colombia, the banks are
happy to not let create APIs,
because they don't believe
themselves as platforms.
They prefer to charge
any type of fees
for whatever they can do it
in the small print letter.
So they get more the
defensive approach,
rather than what you're saying,
seeing themselves as a platform
and monetizing over many
layers of application.
GARY GENSLER: Yeah, I think
that in many countries
and in many incumbents,
they're taking
a sort of guarded approach,
and sort of saying,
no, no, no, this is dangerous
for our business model.
This is dangerous for
our business model.
But to that incumbent that
does that, often they lose out.
It sometimes takes
years to lose out.
But it's that
somebody finds a way
to encroach on that
business model.
And what we're finding
around the globe
is that more and more
countries are promoting this.
Brazil, for instance,
is taking it
to their national legislature.
Now, with the corona crisis, I
haven't stayed closely enough.
It looked like it was
going to pass this spring.
And maybe one of the students
knows whether they did.
But the central bank was
trying to, in essence,
insert more competition, so
that E2O and others in Brazil
had to sort of take a
little bit more competition
in that environment.
So my prediction would
be, even in Colombia, it
would be hard to guard against
this for multiple years.
Maybe a few more years.
But they'll be guarding a
business model that will
have some encroachment on it.
The Bank of
International Settlement
also sort of did
this chart, which
sort of said what's mandatory.
Australia and Europe is
fuller to the mandatory.
That's why they're at
the top of this chart.
And you see the US,
China, Argentina, probably
Colombia, is technically market
driven towards the bottom.
It's also what products?
Is it all about
just funds transfer?
Europe was more about payments.
Was it also about the
underlying product information?
Because if it's
forced upon the banks
from the official sector--
in the US it's not.
But in Europe, in Australia,
Hong Kong, it has been.
If it's sort of by
the official sector,
then it might well
be that you have
to include the product
information, as well as
the information underneath it.
So back to the
market-driven side.
So the market-driven side is
what's happened here in the US.
And what's happened here
in the US-- and I list--
this is not just the US,
but also Europe, Australia,
and some places.
I list about a dozen firms that
are very active in this place.
This is not forced by
the official sector.
This is basically the
private sector saying,
let's avoid that spaghetti wire.
These are companies
that are going
in between all the startups and
the financial firms and saying,
we can provide a standard
way to do these interfaces.
Plaid that I talked
about just announced
it's being sold to
Visa for $5.3 billion.
What do these firms compete on?
They compete on a lot of things.
First is coverage.
If I'm Plaid, do I cover
all the banks that you need?
If I'm a new startup,
and I'm thinking,
should I use Plaid or Yodlee?
And Yodlee and Plaid
are deep competitors.
Maybe one can stay just as
competitive with each other
as Goldman Sachs
and Morgan Stanley.
Yodlee was acquired years ago
by a company called Envestnet.
But Yodlee and Plaid, deep
competitors to each other.
Well first, what
coverage do they have?
As a startup, if I use
Plaid instead of Yodlee,
can I get to all of the banks?
What services do they
give me as a developer?
Obviously, what price?
Are they reliable?
What's their security,
and the like?
So all of these are important.
And one of the sort of
incumbents in this space,
Fiserv bought CashEdge.
And Plaid was being
bought by Visa.
So some of these get caught up.
SaltEdge is in 55 countries.
And then I did a little
research on a paper that
was written three years ago--
or it's really a website
that keeps a list.
And I sort of put together--
this list is three years old.
These are the
account aggregators
in all of these countries.
And I'm sorry, Camilo, I
don't see one for Colombia.
But all of these
companies in some way
built up a business
model to say,
we will serve in these
various countries
to be between the
incumbents and the startups.
We will build some
business model in between.
Now, what can you
do once you do that?
You get a lot of data.
And so what used to be
just a software company--
Plaid, for instance,
started as, in essence, we
can provide this software.
Started to have remarkable
amounts of data.
And that remarkable
amounts of data in Plaid--
founded in 2013, sells
for $5.3 billion to Visa,
or announces the sale,
only 450 employees.
And Forbes estimates it's only
had $109 million of revenues.
So that's nearly
50 times revenues.
Quite a multiple.
You might wonder why
Visa's doing this.
This is from the Visa slides
that Visa announced in January.
This is how they
sort of picture.
They look at Plaid.
They say, Plaid is connected
to 2,600 fintech firms.
That's 2,600 fintech
firms connected to Plaid.
And then Plaid on the
other side provides an API
into 11,000 data sources--
11,000 financial firms.
2,600 fintech firms
connected to Plaid, Plaid
connects to 11,000.
Again, that's the classic
place you want to be.
Plaid is at the bottleneck.
Plaid is at the
gateway, you would say.
And they can collect data
on 200 million users.
Visa thinks there's
a value in that.
We'll have to see.
We'll have to see
whether that ends up
being a good acquisition
for Visa or not.
But these companies
in the middle--
the Plaids, the Yodlees,
have right in the middle
created value.
Romain I'm going to
pause there and see
if there's some discussion
that we can get going.
PROFESSOR 2: [? Iqbal. ?]
AUDIENCE: Yeah, professor.
Can you shed some insight as to
the relationship between Plaid
and the financial institutions?
What's in it for the
financial institutions
to face Plaid in reality?
Were there fees involved?
Because in the example
we looked at some
for some Latin American
countries, such as Brazil,
the incumbents are reluctant
to participate in open API.
And it would be [INAUDIBLE].
GARY GENSLER: It's
a terrific question.
And I'm going to
apologize, because I'm
going to slide back
here on the slides a bit
to go back to something.
This is what they want to avoid.
Even the incumbents don't
want thousands of folks
to enter into
contractual arrangements,
enter into secure private APIs.
Even the incumbents
want to sort of avoid
this spaghetti wire of mess.
Now, it might have been less
strategic and more incremental
that when you think about all
these companies on this list--
these 10 or 12 that have built
up these remarkable businesses,
or around the globe all these--
that many of these started
as small software providers.
And they were saying
to the big incumbents,
we can handle that
spaghetti wire.
We can ensure that
people aren't just screen
scraping and using RPA.
It's going to happen anyway.
You need somebody
to help manage.
And so every modern
online company
in finance and
outside of finance
has to have an AP
management strategy.
You don't normally think about
something in the CEO suite,
this chief executive
officer who's managing this.
But here we are at MIT, I'd
like to bring this technology.
This is an important
technology question
that you need to be
asking is, how are we
managing our
developer community,
our public interface?
Are we going to
do it internally,
or are we going to hire a Plaid?
And I can tell you that
the banks now-- this
has happened in the last
four to seven years.
And many of the banks
are sort of saying,
this has gotten out of hand.
This has gotten out of control.
Is this something
that we really want
to allow the Plaids and
the Yodlees and others
to commercialize our data?
But I think that in part, it
was incrementally decisions
about how to manage
broadly this interface.
And it's also possible
that it wasn't far enough
up in the C-suite, and
it was sort of managed
down in some regards.
But one reaction is this
financial data exchange
that's happened here.
And I've listed the
major founders of FDX.
But Financial Data Exchange--
and this is straight from
their own white paper--
they want to create this group
of remarkably large banks.
I think the members of FDX have
$2 trillion of market value,
if I remember.
Because many of these actually
have $2 trillion balance
sheets.
When you add up all
of these companies,
they've come
together and said, we
want to create standards
for financial data sharing
and secure APIs.
We want to basically not sort of
have the Plaids and the others
commercialize our data.
Even though that's
not in FDX' mandate.
But in some regards, the
cat's already out of the barn.
And now they're
grappling with it.
But the JPMorgans and the
PNC actually, I believe--
which is a large
mid-sized bank in the US--
has stopped having Plaid have
access, if I'm not mistaken.
So it's sort of an interesting
challenge back and forth.
PROFESSOR 2: You now
have Geetha and then Lin.
GARY GENSLER: Geetha's from the
incumbent side going to tell us
why they're using the Plaids.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I just wanted
to make a comment on Plaid
specifically.
We allow access to a number of
fintech lenders to our data,
because then we have no choice.
Because the customer is
providing access to their data,
and we have to allow
them to access it.
To somebody's question
earlier, the biggest problem
with Plaid--
and I'll probably
send some articles
on kind of issues between
Plaid and Capital One.
There was a period of time
when we stopped giving access
to Plaid, because
Plaid wouldn't comply
with any of the standards
that we imposed.
For example, we
needed fintech lenders
to come from certain IPs,
because they looked like bots,
right?
Because they do all
these batch accesses,
and they look like bots.
But Plaid wouldn't comply
with those standards,
and it became very difficult
for us to differentiate Plaid
from a bot.
And even though we had APIs,
they would do screen scraping.
Sometimes they would come
through our mobile channels.
through our web channels.
They would come through any API.
It became really hard for
us to differentiate Plaid
from fraudsters.
So there was a period of
time when we blocked Plaid.
And then they came to the
table, we had conversations,
and then we let them in.
GARY GENSLER: And Geetha,
you were at Cap One?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
Yeah.
GARY GENSLER: So for those
who might not be familiar,
Cap One is one of the largest
credit card banks in the US,
competing head to head with Bank
of America and Citi and Chase,
Discover, and American
Express and so forth.
I sort of call it the Big Seven.
And Cap One's the largest
that isn't in and of itself
one of the big four
banks in the US.
So it's a remarkable
organization,
and it's cut out a big
chunk of its business model
around serving customers
in the credit card space.
And here you're
hearing Gita say,
but we didn't really have a
choice, is what you're saying.
Romane, others?
PROFESSOR 2: Let's go
with Lin, and then Carlos,
if we have time.
GARY GENSLER: Please.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So in the example for Plaid,
it seems like most of the data,
if not all of the data,
is financial data coming
from financial institutions.
I'm just curious to
hear your thoughts
on the market moving towards
using non-financial data.
So customer data in
the retail health
sector to inform or build
financial services upon,
and whether there are
any people doing that.
PROFESSOR 2:
GARY GENSLER: No, it's a
really good observation
that the data aggregators--
I'll go back a slide.
This whole cacophony
from three years
ago around the
globe, or the data
aggregators here in the US--
these big eight or 10
in the US and Europe--
these data aggregators
are largely
about financial data for now.
So their business
strategy-- these dozen
companies, their
business strategies
was sort of API first.
They built an API upon which
they got a network advantage
to get a lot of financial data.
But it is also true that
they could add other data.
And in fact, Plaid
gets bought by Visa.
Yodlee got bought by Envestnet.
And Envestnet is also in asset
management and fund management
and so forth.
I believe you're right.
Your observation is right.
A lot of these "API first,
data aggregator second"
are also going to be adding
other non-financial data.
Alternative data, as
we've talked about,
can come from finance,
like whether you're paying
your utility bill or not.
It can come from finance
and building full cash flow
underwriting models.
But it also can be your
social media footprint.
And it often is.
Alternative data is
about your social media
input and your
footprint, I should say.
Your footprint.
So I think you're right.
Their comparative advantage
is around this financial data.
Plaid, that's their advantage.
I want to note one company
that's on this list here,
I think I included, was Galileo.
Did I?
Yeah, I included Galileo.
Galileo has done a
recent fundraising round
in the middle of 2019.
It's still private.
I think their valuation
was $1.2 billion.
Might have been a little higher.
I can't recall the figure.
So it's a unicorn.
Not many of us have
heard of Galileo.
But two of their big customers--
Chime is one.
I'll just say, Chime is
one fintech company that's
one of their big customers.
Last year, Galileo had a glitch.
And Chime went
down for 24 hours,
because Galileo's standards
in API had a glitch.
So sometimes, you're
that fintech startup
relying upon a Galileo,
in that instance.
And if Galileo software has a
problem, you have a problem.
So there's that challenge
too in the midst of this.
Marqeta has done a
fundraising round.
I think its valuation
is about $2 billion.
Again, still private, still in
the venture land, and so forth.
So there's significant
value that has been built,
API first, data
aggregation second.
And these companies
are all somewhere
between the incumbents and
the developer community
and the startups.
Back to the class, Romain?
PROFESSOR 2: Carlos is up.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So I just want to give
an example of a shout
out to Plaid,
really, for something
they're doing at the moment.
So as part of the SBA PPP
program for emergency funding
for small businesses with
the whole corona crisis,
there's $200 billion being
disbursed over the course
of three months.
And actually probably
this Thursday
there's going to be an
additional $200 billion
approved.
$250, sorry.
So what Plaid is doing
is they're actually
helping, because of their
role as a data aggregator,
to populate the payroll portion
of these loan applications,
because a lot of banks are
trying to do it manually,
which is completely
infeasible, given
the massive size of the
rollout that they're proposing.
So thanks to Plaid and
what they're trying to do,
at least, a lot of
loans can be approved,
or at least applications
submitted exponentially faster.
And that can make a huge
difference for businesses
to survive.
GARY GENSLER: And I thank you
for bringing that information
in.
Do you work with Plaid?
Or have you worked there?
Or is this something you're
reading about online?
AUDIENCE: So I've
been following,
because I work for a
fintech-focused VC that
actually invested in Quovo,
which was acquired by Plaid.
So I know the model pretty well.
GARY GENSLER: These companies
have brought a great deal
more financial inclusion.
These companies have opened
up the banking sector,
to some extent.
And now the banking
sector was probably
going to be opened up
by competitive pressures
in any regard.
But with the Plaids,
earlier Stripe, the Galileos
and the Yodlees and
others, what they've done
is they've brought
some standardization
to that spaghetti wire
that I put earlier--
these interfaces.
They're in the weeds.
To some of us, it might
just be mundane connections.
But they're not.
They're really, really
important connections.
And I would say if you take
anything out of this lecture
and moving forward, if
you're at an incumbent
or you're at a startup,
that you sort of think
about your API strategy.
What is it?
You might not manage it, but
it's good to know what it is.
You might know what your
competitors view of it.
But I agree with Carlos that
in this time of crisis--
the corona crisis in the US, the
program that he's referencing,
was of this $2 trillion package
that Congress just passed,
there was $350 billion
to fund small businesses.
They have to be 500
employees or less.
But small businesses.
It's called a Payroll
Protection Program, PPP.
And through the Small
Business Administration,
it guarantees the
banking sector can
make loans that are forgiven.
So they're forgivable loans
up to $10 million a piece.
They're a loan,
but they're really
a grant if you can show
in your application
that the money is going
to support employment.
And there's various
conditions and conditionality.
And so what Carlos
is talking about
is in the loan applications,
the loan applications
were first being filed
I think last Friday,
but it might have
been over the weekend.
And these loan applications had
to go through your employment
and show who you had earning
less than a certain amount
of dollars per employee.
So a lot of data.
A lot of data.
And it sounds like
Plaid is actually
helping facilitate
that, in some regard.
So thank you.
Romain.
I think I'm getting close to
that 15 minute warning time.
But is there another
question, or are we
just going to move
on to robotic process
automation for a minute?
PROFESSOR 2: I think
we can move on.
And indeed, we have
17 minutes left.
GARY GENSLER: All right.
So let me just
pause for a minute
again on financial
data exchange.
I'm not close
enough to it to know
where they are in
their development.
But basically, a large set
of big incumbents-- and I've
just put a visual of
their principal members.
But then they have behind
this another 50 or 100 second
tier members.
And by second tier,
this is the group
that's primarily running its
board of directors and sort
of coordinating.
And it has all the big US
banks on here, the largest--
Quicken Loans,
which is the largest
in mortgage lending
in the US, and CIFBA,
which is the trade association.
They're coming
together to say, we
need to standardize financial
data sharing standards
for secure authentication and
how this user experience works.
But part of it--
well, part of it is
the incumbents sort
of trying to reclaim a
little bit of the territory.
I don't think the cat's going
to be able to be pushed back
into the barn, so to speak.
Or you might say the
horse is out of the barn,
and I won't use the cat.
But I think that this is an
interesting dynamic that's
going on right now.
Now, you put that in the
context of what we talked about,
robotic process automation.
Robotic process automation
can be used in a positive way
by the incumbents and
by the startups to do
account opening, onboarding,
as we talked about earlier,
loan processing.
Anything that you
can take and automate
that which humans are doing.
And I'm not sort of
moving into chat bots
and the conversational
interfaces
that we've already spoken about.
I'm talking about the more
standardized documents,
reading the documents,
and opening the accounts,
and, as was mentioned
earlier and I maybe
should have put
on this list, also
compliance for any
money laundering
and Know Your Customer.
Those are very positive ways.
But it's also a way
that challenger banks
and challengers can use
it to scrape the data
and pull the data out
of the incumbents,
as long as a customer
permissions it.
So it's sort of both of those
sides in a very positive way
across the entire
field of finance--
a very positive way that
we can automate that which
humans are doing in the past.
This is frankly just the same
as when the tractor came along
and we were automating
what humans and the horse
and the cow and the oxen
were doing in the field.
We can automate that
which the human does.
But it changes the way that--
the sort of dynamic between
incumbents and startups.
And then I want to pause and
see if there are questions.
And then I wanted to say bit
on assignments, and then close.
PROFESSOR 2: We have a
question in the chat for you
from Alex, a Sloan
fellow, who tells us
that one of the readings
one of the authors
ends with consumer will access
financial services from one
central hub.
But then another author
in another reading
speaks of another trend
of embedded fintech.
So which ones of
these perspectives
would you tend to agree with?
GARY GENSLER: Well Alex,
I think that's the debate.
And I think you probably could
guess that I'm at neither end.
I don't think that we'll end
up with truly decentralized
and we can sort of disaggregate.
We had this discussion
a little earlier.
Will it be completely unbundled?
I don't think so.
I think there's still going to
be economic benefits to scale.
Sometimes that's driven
by balance sheet.
The balance sheet financing
side leads to scale,
though securitization and
asset securitization as a way
to rent somebody
else's balance sheet
and to sort of lay off
that risk to somebody else.
But I think that there's a
lot of reasons that scale
and network effects--
balance sheet being one of
the network effects, data
being another network
effect, customer user
interface another
network effect--
that there's benefits
to some scale,
that there will be
some concentration.
Will there be one portal?
Will we go all the
way to one portal?
Will it be that
Amazon will sort of
be the one place I go to for all
of my online financial needs?
Jeff Bezos might have
a strategy that way.
You might write papers that way.
I would caution that
I think that there
will be some
competitive pressures
and economic pressures
on the other side--
that we'll still have
some disaggregation.
For instance, in
country after country,
for decades, there's
been the debate
whether insurance products will
be sold by banks and banking
products by insurance firms.
And for some reason
around the globe
by and large, we still
see this separation.
Some of it's just
legacy and history.
Some of it is regulation.
But it's also how we
think of the products,
that we think of buying
our life insurance
or our household insurance
or auto insurance
a little differently
than we think
about funding the same things.
Funding our house is called a
mortgage and funding our car
is what's called an auto loan.
Now, it's true in some
countries, it's come together.
But by and large,
it's not one portal.
But Alex, do you
have a point of view?
Did you did you feel strongly
one way or the other,
if you're there still?
AUDIENCE: I think the embedded
fintech is quite insightful,
because nowadays
that people talk
about customer-centric
ideas even more than before,
because we have more data to
provide relevant services.
But the thing is that when we
talk about the jobs to be done,
financial services are
not actually the job.
The ultimate job you want to
get done, you want to buy house,
so you need a loan.
Which means that maybe it makes
sense, some of the services
will be the second layer.
I mean, be embedded into
those jobs that really need
to be done by the customers.
GARY GENSLER: I want to
say this about embedded
finance and this concept
that was in the article.
And I'm glad you reminded
me of this, Alex.
I do think that we're
going to see more
what's called embedded finance.
And by that term,
what I take from it--
and it's not a
well-defined term.
You can't look at a
Webster's dictionary
and say what's embedded finance.
But what I take from that term
is that non-financial firms
will embed some
aspect of finance
in their product offering.
Not a new concept.
Even the local grocery
store in the 19th century
was saying you can buy your
groceries and pay tomorrow.
You know, that local merchant.
And that led over 50 or 70
years to the modern credit
card being invented in the 1940s
and taking off by the 1960s.
So we've had some concepts
of embedded finance.
But I think that the
modern technology
will provide more alternatives
to embed a payment mechanism
or a lending mechanism.
And those will be the
two principal things.
Some aspect of a loan or
some aspect of payment right
in an app.
In a sense, like
Uber and Lyft does.
In a sense, like of
point-of-sale lending--
that I can buy
something online and pay
on installment over
four or six payments,
maybe over multiple months.
I think embedded
finance is a trend.
I also do think that because
of this API movement--
and this is a way
to close on APIs--
that startups can
provide services in a way
they couldn't in the past.
That a Robinhood
could come along--
and we'll talk about
Robinhood more when
we talk about capital markets.
But a Robinhood could
come along and say,
we offer that you can
open brokerage accounts
on this handheld device.
You can scan your documents
using robotic process
automation and natural
language processing.
You can scan your documents
by taking a picture
from your phone, open
a brokerage account,
and trade automatically,
interfacing-- there's probably
dozens of APIs that stand
between your Robinhood
app and the New
York Stock Exchange.
And it's not just
Robinhood directly
to the New York Stock Exchange.
There's multiple
interfaces in between.
So I think it's facilitated a
remarkable shift in finance,
that we can do those things
right on our cell phones.
And embedded finance and
these APIs relate to it.
I'm just not quite
there that it will all
be bundled up into
one service provider,
or that it will
all be fragmented.
I think we'll have a
little bit in between.
I just want to mention
something on assignments,
because the April 8th.
Again, assignments--
particularly at this stage,
where we're pass emergency,
no credit emergency,
or sort of colloquially
pass/fail--
assignments are a great way
to engage in this subject.
I think of that even when we
have A's and B's and things
like that.
I just really ask you to
engage in this subject.
Pick some subject that
interests you, that excites you,
and you want to write
to an incumbent,
to a big tech firm like
Amazon or Andreessen Horowitz.
Which Andreessen Horowitz owns a
slice of a lot of the companies
we've been talking
about already.
I mean, they're a remarkable
venture capital firm.
And just think of some
sort of strategy around it.
The individual
papers are just a way
to break up the
assignment in a way
that one person
would write about it.
Overall market
analysis, somebody
doing the technological trends.
If you pick that you're writing
to Amazon about, let's say,
the consumer lending space, what
are the technological trends
really doing to that space?
Who are the
traditional competitors
and who are the big
tech competitors?
And just breaking it up three or
four pages, 900 to 1,200 words.
Again, we're just helping you
kind of engage in a subject.
PROFESSOR 2: Perhaps you
can answer another question
that I've received from a
student who does not understand
how Plaid makes money.
What is the business model?
GARY GENSLER: With only $110
million in revenues-- now,
that's a Forbes estimate--
you sort of go, wait a minute?
How does this work?
But how the space makes money--
not just Plaid, but
how API companies make
money in finance and outside of
finance is they do charge fees.
I apologize, I don't know if
it's a penny a transaction
or what it is.
And maybe somebody on
this call actually knows--
Gita or others know their
actual revenue model.
But charging a very small
fraction of money per trade.
And then what they do
is data aggregation.
And with that data
in other fields,
then you try to see how
you can commercialize
that data by cross-selling
either directly.
Or remember, a lot
of these companies
like Plaid and Galileo
and others are in between.
They're behind the scenes,
between one side of the market
and another side of the market.
But when you create
that like Twilio,
Twilio is an 80% market share
between voice and messaging
and things like that--
in the US, at least.
So all of a sudden,
then you can either
enhance your fee
structure, because you're
such dominant
oligopolies, sort of.
You can collect economic rent.
Or you commercialize the data.
And it's the data
aggregation side--
I think Visa's paying what
might be 25 or 50 times revenues
for that data aggregation side.